here's a non-hypothetical
I'm really happy I'm with Karen
[Music]
look how cute he is
he's trying to shoot with a smoke
grenade I'm sorry I did nothing you just
concentrate on turning around
I just just tap s then d
any last words no what
wow
it's like go bad
hey can I have a ride then I uh I have
my bike
no way dude I am not driving home
I brought an inflatable bed for just
such occasions you're welcome to share
it though it's a roomy twin
okay
hey dummy get in the car
I'm a drunk driver
yes you are
here let me take that
just to get the car
really hold your liquor Billy you can't
okay
and I am just going to lie down in the
back that's all right sure
here's your bag
just don't puke on anything
you okay so good good what's going on
with Fairfield County Schools Karen did
you generate that price list
um
I will I'm sorry okay just get it done
Jim will you make sure
oh yeah definitely
suck up
Josh did you hear what I said thank you
everyone
damn it
what's up
uh nothing we're just out of hers chips
oh but don't worry about it my snack
food doesn't fall under the umbrella of
your Authority
and that's where you're wrong
I'm your project supervisor today
and I have just decided that we're not
doing anything
until you get the chips that you require
so I think we should go get some
now please
this is Mike from the West Side Market
well we got a shipment of hers salt and
vinegar chips and we ordered about three
weeks ago and have
yeah
you have in the warehouse great
what is my store number
six
wait no I'll call you back
shut up
hey um I think I am going to take that
job
and Scranton
it's not that bad so
they offer you a job there
I think you should take it
okay yeah maybe I will
yeah I'm I'm happy you said that I mean
I don't think he's into me or anything
but
I'm kind of into him
so there you go
ow
what happened a bread on your desk I
just picked it up it's white hot
but Jim this garlic bread is cold what
no
it burned me hi
bizarre
no
I'm in crisis at a time
hey
you see that guy behind you in the blue
blazer against the wall
yep that's Drake and just you know I
don't want to be weird or anything but
um we used to date oh
okay cool thanks for telling me and it
didn't end up
gotcha
all right
well it's nice meeting you guys take
care
well if you're wondering why his wife
was staring daggers at me that's because
I kind of saw him for a little bit when
they were separated
I didn't know this really I thought it
was so obvious
I'm glad to make you uncomfortable no
before I knew you so it's fine you stay
here and have fun because I'm gonna go
out back and shoot hoops with David
Wallace okay oh
um don't mention that you and I are
dating because I think he might still
have feelings for me Wallace
what the hell have you dated like every
guy here
wow
okay okay you got me I so got you so
none of them
of course not
I mean you're kind of like my first
really
God it's so easy it's not even fun
oh stop stop stop there's a hole I just
step over the hole yep come on on lazy
bones move it
perfect oh just made it okay turn left
come on
I apologize for yelling at you I'm
trying to bring the team spirit on your
team is that another hole take a big
step
[Laughter]
so we have all night where do you want
to go first I don't know how about the
U.N
come here
um every time my sixth grade class goes
on a field trip
I think you're really gonna enjoy this
adult gym
yeah we went to the spotted ping for
dinner it's in the village uh Karen knew
it and then we second acted Spamalot
that's when you sneak in at intermission
with all the smokers
and then we went to a bar that used to
be a church oh and at this one bar I
swear I saw Lauren Michaels that wasn't
him
so what's gonna happen with us when I
get this job what do you mean I get the
job
well if you get the job
then I'd move here a few
did you move with me
I'm not stupid okay I was at the beach
I don't have a future in Scranton
there's one too many people there
you mean Kevin
exactly
oh but you get it right
I can't stay there yeah
I do
come on